coastal mullet is germany's most famous
psychiatric patient now the 56 year-old
seen here in file footage is a free man
again pending his retrial judges at the
court in nuremberg rules that the
original psychological evaluation which
classified him as a danger to the public
was invalid and assoc the judges ruled
that the 2002 evaluation is in fact in
legal terms false because it has not
adequately been shown that the doctor
who issued it also carried out the
examination mullets case began over 11
years ago when his wife filed assault
charges against him during the trial
mullet accused his wife of using her
position as an assets consultant at
Germany's who prefer ines bank to
smuggle money into Switzerland years
after he was committed for extreme
paranoia new evidence proves mullet was
telling the truth Milosh believes his
conviction was part of a larger
conspiracy but the state minister of
justice underlined the Independence of
the judiciary in China wind is I cannot
comment on the court's decision but I
can say that I believe the case will be
reviewed in order to clarify any
lingering questions in a--let's wife
will oust suomen the case has now been
reopened a new court will decide whether
coastal mullet was the victim of a gross
miscarriage of justice